[Musique]
le président péruvien pedro castillo a
fait une annonce choc samedi en
indiquant que le pérou à les imposer la
castration chimique à tous les violeurs
pédophiles
nous allons appliquer la castration
chimique comme l'une des mesures
drastiques contre les violeurs de
mineurs d'un adolescent et deux femmes
une mesure qui intervient alors que le
pays a été secoué par une violente
affaires de gueule sur une petite fille
de 3 ans qui a été kidnappé torturé et
abusé sexuellement la castration
chimique consiste en une injection à peu
près tous les trois mois pour diminuer
les pulsions sexuelles pour réduire le
risque de récidive mais ce traitement
peut aussi avoir des effets indésirables
importants la castration chimique c'est
pas une solution idéale
ce traitement est déjà mise en place en
russie en pologne ou encore l'indonésie
pour sous les violeurs la castration
chimique de force il sans aucun
consentement à leur demande et alors la
castration chimique pour les pédophiles
autorisé au pérou faut-il la même chose
en france
[Musique]
oui oui valérie v ça existe déjà en
france sauf que la différence de cette
proposition péruvienne c'est qu'en
france c'est proposer aux prisonniers
libre à lui ensuite de décider de le
faire ou pas et ça et en revanche la
castration chimique obligatoire elle
existe aussi en russie en pologne en
corée du sud en indonésie
vous n'êtes pas pour totalement contre
alors cette affairé horrible les
agressions d'enfants quelles qu'elles
soient sont horribles mais la castration
chimique c répond à la barbarie par la
barbarie pour moi et c'est d'ailleurs
considérée comme une mutilation génitale
c'est pour ça que c'est refuser engeance
moi je ne souhaite pas que ce soit mais
bien sûr mais on répond pas la barbarie
de marc la même chose
merci de ne pas répondre comme tu dis
parra barbarie table mais on peut aussi
se protéger à partir du moment où car un
homme est parti chercher une petite
fille de trois ans il a agressé la
violer il a une érection pour une petite
fille de 3 ans qu'est-ce qui va foot
avec moi nuit sur sa sueur sur ma terre
sur ma planète tu le cas frais c'est
fini c'est le jeu m'excuser mais oui
mais c'est la sidération je
sais quoi c'est réversible
en
fait c'est mon linge action trimestriel
ou alors c'est des médicaments et puis
si ça si on arrête le truc est dans le
titre et récupère sa
définition en israël sera sera il sera
convoqué on recommence mois si demain
quelqu'un viol une gamine ou même
quelqu'un de ma famille qu'à 5/6 ans je
ne veux pas dire on commence sur
quelqu'un d'autre je veux pas qu'on dise
et bats la barbarie sur la barbarie oui
je remets de la barbarie sur de la
barbarie c'est comme ça c'est réglé ben
y'a pas à discuter
non mais pas du tout pour la même raison
que gilles parce que d'abord la
castration chimique ça marche sur 10 5
face aux intérêts des psys cas ça marche
sur 10 à 15 % des dons mais sinon ça
mais
la question c'est voilà pour la
castration physique il ya un pédophile
récidiviste qui a envoyé une lettre au
président de la république pour lui
demander qu'on écoute les testicules
donc moi je vais beaucoup plus loin que
la castration chimique qui ne marche pas
et ayant des mandats n'ont pas la lola
dont canon mais carrément map attente on
parle d'enfants de 3 ans moi je n'ai
alors la barbarie ça ne me dérange pas
du tout il faut aller au bout de femme
et oui du projet voilà assez inquiète un
peu inquiet par les propos jean parce
qu'on le sait bien qu'il ya 40% de
récidivistes chez mur la barbarie par
l'ats barbara et les mecs il faut
presque l'or et des coûts qui regardent
aujourd'hui normal le landais abc lévis
marc dutroux va essayer de bien ce
qu'ils sont ce sont tous des récits
liste donc il n'y a pas de questions à
se poser et tu sais bien qu'à un moment
donné il sort de taule et les mecs on
l'aimé en plus à côté de leurs victimes
les mecs bien sûr bien évidemment qu'il
faut répondre de cette manière là comme
le font les russes sans consentement et
on parle souvent de peines ridicules
parce que c'est ça aussi ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que le problème c'est que
c'est des peines sont ridicules qu'ils
sont voilà et souvent des remises de
peine et des peines qui sont pas
appliquées le seul problème avec la
castration chimique c'est que c'est
forcément sous la base du volontariat
puisque au bout de trois mois ça
s'arrête donc il faut que la personne
elle revient six directeurs mais les
termes d'audience ils sont tous suivis
quelques subsides qu'ils sont tous
suivis en plus il n'y a pas de
volontariat normalement t'es pas à
moitié était pas t'as pas être
volontaire n'ait sorti tu peux pas aller
chercher le lait quand tu fais le
pourquoi des tchèques 16e il a pas
d'identité lajemmerais bill a pas
d'identité comment tu fais pour le
trouver c'est à travers ce qu'il a fait
ce les ja je te laisse en vie estime toi
je te laisse en vie mais je vais venir
chercher oui ça va choquer estime toi
heureux je te laisse en vie je le redis
encore une fois vient présenter je vais
te castrés
gamine de conserver 165 mille enfants
victimes de viol ou d'attouchements
chaque année non mais bon bah oui oui
volontariat c'est pour ça que personne
n'a relevé ce que dany disait mais en
fait elle est d'accord avec nous et
joris que tu es d'accord final c'est
trop de très trop de taf d'aller
chercher les personnes tous les trois
mois personne peut faire ce truc là tu
n'as pas déjà le ton pour autre chose on
n'a pas le temps pour ça donc à ce
moment là tu le castres physiquement
mais c'est en termine 6ème de las vegas
rien ne va plus au il y avait des glaces
que ça n'atteint qu'un gamin 3 en 6 ans
14 ans 12 ans déjà le viol n'est jamais
à louzac aucun regard hagard alors elle
n'y a pas à se poser des questions tu as
fais ça tu le sais maintenant le mec qui
braquent une montre c'est différent le
mec il fait des conneries c'est
différent il va passer devant un
tribunal et on va lui dire 'est-ce que
tu regrettes oui je regrette la
rédemption pas de problème rappelle que
la semaine est celle des enfants rouges
pas aux enfants mais c'est des gens dit
là il ne faut pas pour moi c'est pas
l'heure avec un enroulé eplatures junior
et c'est pour ça que je te dis qu'on est
d'accord et qu'il suffit de faire une
fois physiquement et moi j mais raymond
j'entends ce que vous dites c'est
parfaitement respectable l'agression
d'un enfant c'est inhumain c'est barbare
mais là et comme nicolas vous êtes en
train de dire que finalement quelqu'un
qui a agressé un enfant il faut le
mutiler oui
excusez moi mais alors quelqu'un qui a
tué quelqu'un qu'est-ce qu'il faut lui
faire à ce moment-là on peut changer
complètement la loi française ok tu ne
vois pas la même chose parfois mais si
c'est la même chose maintenant chose que
viol un an parfois n'est pas c'est dur
mais elle existe c'est très drôle et
c'est sur la base du volontariat moi je
trouve que c'est bien beau
mais le problème c'est sa façon et il
ressort très laid et l'association
attend des maires de la mrc
sans pitié que les pédophiles là ça
permet de lutter à la fois contre la
récidive on l'a dit les récidivistes
sont nombreux et surtout de prévenir
parce qu'aujourd'hui à des gens qui sont
conscients d'avoir une attirance
sexuelle pour les enfants que sont
dépensés ces ignobles et malsaine et
qu'ils voient là je veux me faire
traiter et si ça permet d'éviter un
drame évidemment qu'il faut le faire
pour guillaume a raison oui et que tous
les pays civilisés presse aux quelques
exceptions n'adopte pas la casse
traction comme ça
ils ont réfléchi il fut chef barbara et
c'est celui qui va s'attaquer à un bond
de 3 go rim et moi le reste il n'y a pas
de discussion tué mon père au binion's
et fin de l'histoire et clarisse
populiste annonce alors je pense
sincèrement à dire franchement dans ce
cas précis on le fait on
les croise mais j'y vois pas ce qui
est arrivé j'ai envie de tuer quand même
la personne donc ne serait ce que par
respect pour ses parents vous regardez
le cas de quelqu'un qu'on connaît tous
avec ça a été traitée ici sur le cas de
vanessa ce marigot rail gabriel matzneff
qui est quand même un violeur pédophile
qui a écrit des livres sur la relation
qu'il avait avec des petits enfants de
4-5 ans le mec là ils se baladent il est
peinard il vient même de demander à la
mairie de paris soutenu par florence
berthou qu'on lui refasse la salle de
bain de son studio hlm à paris donc je
veux dire c'est super le mec il est au
top du top en balade machin je veux dire
il n'y a pas de question à se poser là
dessus au gym il faut absolument que ces
mecs là il soit qu'ils ne puissent plus
nuire à personne non mais là on va même
pas qu'ils soient encore en vie entre
new team ah oui voilà la déco 10
comprend pas que son entraîneur mais
c'est quand même pas un pédophile dont
il n'y a aucune compassion pour raconter
les pédophiles alors
est-ce que la castration physique et
c'est vraiment très difficile moi je
suis je n'y a pas il n'ya pas c'est pas
négociable je ne négocie pas fait dire
les mots je négociais pas je ne négocie
pas avec un mec qui a une érection pour
un enfant tu ne peux pas avoir
d'érection pour un enfant sinon faut que
tu te fasses soigner sans avoir une
deuxième chance d'en attraper c'est mort
tu veux tu peux pas gilles tu ne peux
pas voir un direction tu peux pas avoir
une érection par un enfant de 3 ans 5
ans 10 ans c'est pas possible comment
elle fonctionne à défaut des ces mecs là
on les met devant des femmes de 20 à 30
ans il arrive pas abandonner si les
veaux coacher il dit il faut une
deuxième chance question non la deuxième
chance je passe les absences je vais 610
change la deuxième chance c'est quoi
l'émergence il a violé un enfant de
trois ans deuxième chance il va il va
violer 15 à 3 ans il aura pas de
deuxième choix il va s'il va violer
quelqu'un que je connais qu'à six ans et
on va me dire au tribunal vous savez il
a déjà faire n'est pas parfait alors
pourquoi vous l'avez laissé recommencer
à bas parce que vous savez on répond pas
à la barbarie par de la barbacane
attendant moi mon petit il est brisé
c'est sûr ça vienne briser sûr mais j'ai
pas répondre à barbarie alors je vais
croiser le mec que tu as dû lire et on
n'a pas répondu par la barbarie est allé
deux baguettes vaches et du pain et
collet continue des conneries ben on
vous sent sais pas si c'est bénéfique
oui j'entends mais vous pensez pas que
si c'était efficace et si c'était la
solution un pays comme la france qui a
énormément réfléchi là dessus le sénat
encore récemment aurait adopté n'a pas
le courage
on a bien réfléchi en 2018 le rockeur en
2018 laurent wauquiez avait évoqué cette
possibilité est une question chimique
obligatoire
et aussi le gars le prisonnier refusé
c'était prison à vie c'était une
proposition de loi qui n'affecte n'a pas
été adopté la base c'était très bien
sauf qu'on n'a pas le courage parce
qu'on regarde les autres pays on est
tout le temps en train de dire enfin si
les autres le font pas le ferai
moi je salue le président du pérou la
raison ne pas être allé vivre au pérou
et c'est ça non mais l'épée les pings
les pédophiles parce que c'est une
maladie on les soigne alors ils sortent
de prison ils font des petites peines
assez franchement c'est terrible on peut
se poser quand même la question de cette
justice française qui fait quand même
deux poids deux mesures avec des gens
qui font pas le des braquages mais à un
moment donné tu oublies j'ai aussi de
faire un petit peu la balance et te dire
comment ça se fait qu'un mec à biot les
uns ou de gauche il peut sortir au bout
de six ceintures et recommencer alors
quelqu'un qui a braqué cinq banques
directes dans le sac en prison sur voila
on peut
chasser d'accord c'est d'accord avec toi
c'est quand même bizarre l'annoncé
rester là c'est la question qu'il faut
se poser qui n'a pas réagi là-dessus
bertrand deckers oui moi alors
moi ce que je peux vous dire par contre
c'est que je vous vois venir mais en
belgique doit venir prochainement on a
été profondément marquée masquer les
affaires du trauma bien sûr et tout le
réseau qui va être démantelée n'est
vraiment en belgique d'une petite ville
qui s'arrêtent marcinelle on a fait
énormément de choses nous contre la
pédophilie et voilà c'est tout pour nous
c'est vraiment une problématique et
skill auquel on ne touche pas les
marches blanches j'aime c'est la
belgique qui n'ont
pour se voir depuis deux ans marc
dutroux et à deux d'entre eux
sony en poudre est sorti pour le clip on
le sait très bien
j'ai toujours on marche soit way battant
tuer ça fait une gym si si il a voulu la
paix la
tuer sa peine donc
présent ils ont à vide ont fait appel
il n'est pas question la justice mais
j'ai pas stupides et tout ça non sire et
le moi je dis simplement qu'en france il
n'y a pas de peine sauf de très rares
exceptions de prison à vie jusqu'à la
mort du prisonnier nous notre justice
c'est que ce n'est pas vous dire
définitive voilà c'est que quand on a
purgé sa peine on peut ressortir alors
j'entends que la récidive il faut lutter
contre ça mais si on met les gens
définitivement tous en prison dans les
prisons c'est le connard